[Música]
Muy bien pues vamos a conocer entonces
detalles de lo que está sucediendo en
Ecuador ya hemos hablado de la crisis
carcelaria y de seguridad que se está
presentando en este país ecuatoriano
vamos en este país suramericano vamos a
hablar entonces con Gustavo Ortega
nuestro corresponsal permanente en la
ciudad de Quito Gustavo muy buenas
noches allí en la capital ecuatoriana
Hace algunos minutos se pronunció el
presidente Guillermo lasso a través de
un corto mensaje brevemente Qué fue lo
que dijo el mandatario sobre esta crisis
carcelaria esta crisis de seguridad
si efectivamente de Santiago Buenas
noches Hace algunos minutos se pronunció
al presidente de la república se
esperaba que sería una cadera nacional
pero se metió un corto mensaje por parte
del Ejecutivo en nacional que ha dicho
el presidente de la República en
principio ha llamado a toda la
ciudadanía y a los organismos del estado
A unirse contra la lucha
en contra de la criminalidad y la lucha
contra el narcotráfico básicamente lo
que he dicho en su mensaje es que no se
pretenda solapar el uso de los Derechos
Humanos para no defender a la ciudadanía
sobre todo por lo que sucede en las
cárceles ecuatorianas debes recordarte
también que en lo que va de año han
muerto aproximadamente 400 personas
asesinadas dentro de las cárces
únicamente y 3.500 personas han muerto
por hechos de muerte violencia a nivel
en general en todo el país en este
sentido se produce también el décimo
alzamiento carcelario en el país desde
febrero de 2021 hasta la fecha que ha
dicho también el presidente de la
república ha rechazado algunos este
parlamento que llamaban inclusive a lo
que él ha calificado como desestabilizar
en la democracia porque según también
algunos parlamentarios llamaban a
activar el fantasma nuevamente a la
muerte Cruzada que significa la
disolución de la asamblea nacional en la
rechazado este procesamiento por parte
de algunos sectores de El parlamento De
igual forma también ha adelantado no ha
dado detalles pero adelantado que se ha
discutido un plan para
luchar en un plan de corto mediano plazo
para luchar así por el control de las
penitenciarias del país ha resaltado
también que ya se mantiene el control de
la penitenciaría del litoral que sirve
la ciudad de Guayaquil y De igual forma
ha dicho que adelantarán un plan para
luchar así contra la criminalidad
Gustavo También tenemos que hablar de
los hechos que tuvieron lugar en la
penitenciaría del litoral en la ciudad
de Guayaquil que junto con la provincia
de esmeraldas y la provincia de guayas
están bajo estado de excepción y son
unas de las más afecta en Ecuador qué
fue lo que pasó en la jornada de hoy
pero básicamente para entrar en contexto
qué es lo que ha pasado desde el 30 de
octubre hasta la fecha se han producido
30 atentados uno de ellos con explosivos
o sea se ha producido en el país se
produjo secuestro de guías
penitenciarios que ya fueron liberados
ese punto se pusieron asesinatos de
policías se propusieron alzamientos en
diferentes ciudades del país tanto en
guayas en Esmeralda y en Santo Domingo
se pronunciaron el día de hoy inclusive
10 ante Estados con explosivos con
carros bombas específicamente y esto ha
generado las reacciones de distintos
sectores del ejecutivo nacional se ha
pedido inclusive tomar algunas medidas
como armar la población a los ciudadanos
se ha pedido también el pasado judicial
de las personas que ingresan este país
se ha pedido también derogar algunas
leyes que según algunas autoridades
estarían protegiendo a los delincuentes
pero en este momento El Ejecutivo
nacional ha dicho que ya se mantiene el
control de el centro carcelario de la
penitenciaría del litoral y ha dicho que
ha llamado también a la unidad de todos
los ciudadanos Gustavo Muchas gracias
por el reporte y esta última hora de lo
que ha dicho el presidente de Guillermo
lasso allí en Ecuador